HIMSELF, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: MATT FINN,
THANK YOU FOR THE UPDATE,
APPRECIATE IT.
IN GEORGIA LAST WEEK, TWO PEOPLE
GOT INTO AN ARGUMENT AT A
SUPERMARKET IN A SAME SOCIETY
THAT WOULD BE THE END AND NOBODY
HEARD ABOUT IT AND THOSE
INVOLVED MOVED ON WITH THEIR
LIVES.
THIS IS NO LONGER A SANE
SOCIETY.
SO A FELLOW SHOPPER TOLD GEORGIA
LAWMAKER ERIKA THOMAS SHE HAD
TOO MANY ITEMS TO USE EXPRESS
CHECKOUT LANE, SHE HAD
IMMEDIATELY ACCUSED HIM OF BEING
EVIL AND ATTACKED HIM ON THE
BASIS OF HIS RACE.
>> PEOPLE ARE GETTING OUT OF
CONTROL WITH THIS.
WITH THIS WHITE PRIVILEGE.
>> THIS WHITE MAN COMES UP TO ME
AND SAYS, YOU LAZY SON OF A
[BLEEP], THEY HATE ISRAEL.
THAT WHITE MAN TO COME UP TO ME
AND CALL ME A LAZY SON OF A
[BLEEP] AND GO BACK WHERE I CAME
FROM BECAUSE HE HAD A COUPLE OF
ITEMS THAT HE WANTED TO GET IN
FRONT OF ME?
WHAT WOULD MAKE YOU THAT ANGRY
TO SAY SOMETHING LIKE THAT?
>> OMAR, AND STUFF LIKE THAT.
BUT IT'S GETTING OUT OF CONTROL.
THERE IS SO MUCH HATE IN THIS
WORLD.
IT IS BEING DECIDED BY THE
PRESIDENT EVERY SINGLE DAY.
>> Tucker: SO THE PRESS HAVING
FORGOTTEN THE LAST TWO OR THREE
HATE CRIMES IMMEDIATELY BELIEVED
THOMAS COMPLETELY AND BLAMED THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR CREATING A
CLIMATE OF HATE.
AND THEY STILL BELIEVE HER NOW
IF THE MAN SHE ACCUSED DIDN'T
COME FORWARD ON HIS OWN.
BUT HE DID COME FORWARD, HIS
NAME IS ERIC SPARKS.
HE'S NOT A MEMBER OF THE PLAN,
IT TURNS OUT HE'S CUBAN AND A
DEMOCRAT, AN AVID LIBERAL
DEMOCRAT.
HE SAYS THOMAS LIED COMPLETELY
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED.
THOMAS DIDN'T EVEN FIGHT BACK.
IN AN INTERVIEW WITH THE
TELEVISION STATION, SHE SAID
SPARKS NEVER SAID GO BACK WHERE
YOU CAME FROM.
BUT IT DIDN'T MATTER TO
"THE NEW YORK TIMES."
AND TO STATE THE KEY FACTS
FIRST, "NEW YORK TIMES" DOES THE
OPPOSITE.
THE HEADLINE SAID "GO BACK WHERE
YOU CAME FROM, GEORGIA LAWMAKER
SAID SHE WAS TOLD."
BUT SHE SAID SHE WAS NOT TOLD
THAT.
IN THE STORY, THE TIMES WITH 14
PARAGRAPHS FOR TELLING YOU THE
READER THAT THOMAS ACTUALLY
RETRACTED HER PHONY ACCUSATION.
BUT IT SEEMS LIKE FRAUD.
AND THE AUTHOR OF PANIC ATTACK,
RADICALS IN THE AGE OF TRUMP
JOINS US, ROBBIE YOU HAVE DONE
JOURNALISM YOUR WHOLE ENTIRE
LIFE.
IF YOU RUN A STORY WITH THE
HEADLINE THAT IS COMPLETELY
FALSE, AND YOU KNOW WHAT IS
FOALS AND IN FACT AND GRAFT 14
YOU CONCEDE IT IS FOALS, THAT IS
NOT REALLY JOURNALISM, IS IT?
IT SOMETHING ELSE?
>> NO, IT'S NOT.
IT'S NOT MUCH OF A STORY.
IT STARTS TO MAKE YOU WONDER WHY
WAS THIS WRITTEN?
WHO DECIDED A TRIVIAL DISPUTE
BETWEEN TWO COSTRESSED OUT A
NATIONAL NEWS ITEM AND OUTLINE
NATIONAL NEWS ITEM BUT ONE THAT
CONFIRMS ALL OF THE BIASES OF TH
CONFIRMS ALL OF THE BIASES OF TE
NEW YORK TIME READERS ABOUT WHAT
IS GOING ON IN TRUMP AMERICA
ET CETERA, ET CETERA.
EVERY STORY MUST BE ABOUT TRUMP,
RIGHT?
IT'S ABOUT RACISM AND TRUMP.
THAT ANGLE HAS TO BE IN THERE
AND WE HAVE TO FIND IT.
THAT IS THE OPERATING THINKING
OF SO MANY PEOPLE IN THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA.
WHEN THIS WAS JUST NEWS,
SOMETHING THAT HAPPENED THAT
HAPPENS TO PEOPLE.
YOU KNOW, I THINK THE GUY WAS
KIND OF A JERK.
I THINK SHE WAS A JERK.
PEOPLE ARE JERKS TO EACH OTHER.
THAT IS IT.
THERE IS NO STORY HERE.
>> Tucker: SO MAYBE THE REAL
POINT OF THE STORY HAD NOTHING
TO DO WITH ERIKA THOMAS OR
SPARKS WHO FALSELY ACCUSED PER
PERPETRATOR, BUT IT IS ABOUT THE
PEOPLE WRITING THE STORY.
AND THE MESSAGE THEY ARE SENDING
IS FOR GOOD PEOPLE.
WE ARE NOT LIKE THE PRESIDENT.
WE ARE VIRTUOUS.
IT DOES SEEM LIKE A STORY THAT
IS NARCISSISM THAT ARE DESIGNED
TO MAKE THE PERSON TELLING THE
STORY SEEM LIKE A REALLY GOOD
PERSON.
>> YES, THEY WANT THEY ARE GOOD
AND THEY WANT YOU TO BE ANGRY.
THEY WANT YOU TO BE CONFUSED AND
ANGRY AND THINK EVERYONE IS OUT
TO GET YOU BECAUSE THAT IS WHAT
SELLS IN NEWSPAPERS OR ATTRACTS
MORE PEOPLE TO CLICK ON THE
ARTICLE IF THERE ARE PEOPLE,
THERE IS SOMETHING YOU SHOULD BE
MAD ABOUT.
EVERYBODY IS MAD ABOUT IT.
WHY AREN'T YOU WORKED UP ENOUGH
YET IS THE KIND OF PREVAILS ON
THIS SOCIAL MEDIA CULTURE WHERE
YOU SEE SOMETHING, LOOKS BAD,
YOU DECIDED THERE IS NO NEED TO
FOLLOW UP.
THESE STORIES ARE ALWAYS MORE
COMPLICATED, EVEN WHEN THEY ARE
TRUE.
THERE WAS SOMETHING MORE
COMPLICATED ABOUT THEM.
AND WE ARE TOO QUICKLY, WE ARE
NOT LOOKING INTO THAT BECAUSE
NO, WE KNOW WHAT WE THINK
ALREADY.
AND IT MUST BE THIS IS ABOUT